the Supreme Court tossing the conviction
of a black death row inmate in
Mississippi
Curtis flowers was tried six times for
the same quadruple murder in all six by
the same prosecutor the justices ruled
in favor of his jury discrimination case
Jeff the case has more justice Brett
Kavanaugh wrote that a white Mississippi
prosecutors goal was to have an
all-white jury decide the fate of an
african-american man accused of murder
which is unconstitutional the courts
newest justice said that district
attorney Doug Evans waged a relentless
determined effort to rid the jury of
black individuals it was Curtis flowers
sixth trial for the same quadruple
murder Cavanaugh pointed to a pattern
noting that Evans had removed 41 of the
42 prospective black jurors over the six
trials it began in July of 1996 when
four people were shot to death
execution-style in a Winona Mississippi
furniture store upon his arrest
prosecutors called flowers a disgruntled
former employee who sought revenge
against the store's owner the shopping
of all about the entire system the case
gained notoriety in part because the
podcast in the dark which tracked down
witnesses and raised questions about
flowers guilt Sherry Lynn Johnson is
flowers lawyer I think that when seven
members of this court which is often
divided are agreed that there was racial
discrimination then that's a powerful
signal that both something went terribly
wrong and that the Supreme Court cares
about it she says the flowers was happy
with the decision even though he's now
facing a possible seventh trial for the
murders for CBS this morning Saturday
Jeff Pegues Washington absolutely
incredible story now they're double
jeopardy this was like times three yeah
and it took that much to actually make
to reverse it to make it happen
makes you wonder how many other cases
like that right many yeah I'm sure